it's been a big year for twist endings
so far we've seen heroes turn into
villains villains turn into allies
secret societies at work life-altering
decisions and even one movie that turned
out to partially take place in a video
game these are the biggest plot twists
of 2019 so far spoilers ahead the
marketing of us presented the film as a
home invasion thriller with a dark
secret that secret seems to get revealed
when red explains the nature of the
tethered and why she decided to stage an
uprising for her people it's a twist of
sorts but it's really more of an
explanation then the real twist arrives
at the very end of the movie when
Adelaide realizes via a long repressed
memory that she's actually the tethered
one and that red was her original self
who she strangled and hid down in the
tunnels so she can attempt to live a
normal life
in retrospect did explains so much but
even if some viewers guessed it from the
beginning watching it all build to that
moment remains intensely satisfying
there are a number of exciting
developments in the much-anticipated and
divisive final season of Game of Thrones
which could be considered important
twists if we're talking about truly
massive twist though we have to talk
about the mad Queen and the fall of
Daenerys Targaryen though it had been
foreshadowed in various ways throughout
the series
danny's turned from righteous crusader
for the oppressed to full-on genocide
all dragon rider happened so quickly in
the midst of the show's final season
that many fans were caught off guard the
episode in which she reached the point
of no return the bells is one of the
most harrowing moments in the entire
series and some viewers still have their
jaws on the floor in 2016 M night
Shyamalan pulled off what might be the
biggest twist of his career with the
surprise reveal that his thriller split
was actually a secret sequel to his 2000
classic unbreakable glasses a follow-up
to both films that brings together the
heroes and villains of each story into
one superhero universe but it gets even
wilder from there it turns out that
Kevin Wendell crumb aka the hoard and
David Dunn aka bee overseer are not the
most powerful forces in their world as
their final clash is underway Shyamalan
reveals that they were brought together
not to be studied or have their
superpowers revealed but to be executed
by a secret society determined
keep the balance by wiping out gifted
people then of course Shyamalan couldn't
help but throw in another twist by
making the brilliant mr. glass construct
a counter scheme that resulted in proof
of superheroes being released to the
world establishing the potential for an
even bigger universe and presumably even
more twists to come Avengers endgame was
only ever going to end one way with the
Avengers finding a path to defeating
Thanos and restoring their snapped out
friends to life after the events of
infinity war we knew that going in the
only mystery was in how it would happen
and the film through viewers for a loop
just a few minutes into the adventure
the stage is set for an Avengers vs.
Thanos rematch almost right away but
when the surviving members of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes get to him Thanos
reveals that he's already destroyed the
Infinity stones they used the stones to
destroy the stones but the work is done
Thor executes Stano said before we can
even get over the shock of that death
the film jumps ahead five years to show
a seemingly dude world the 2019 film
adaptation of Stephen King's Pet
Sematary didn't attempt to hide its
major alterations to the source material
some of the film's earliest trailers
gave a way that the new movie was going
to make the Creed families eldest child
Ellie the victim of a tragic early death
and even more tragic resurrection that
runs contrary to King's book which kills
off the family's youngest child gage it
was a big change that seemed to allow
the filmmakers more leeway to play with
the psychological terror while also
upping the violence factor of the undead
child it was also a brilliant bait and
switch hiding the film's real twist the
original story ends with Lewis Creed's
killer undead son murdering his wife
which then drives Lewis to bury her in
the cemetery to bring her back as an
undead ghoul as well in the new film the
undead Ellie kills both her mother and
father and buries them in the cemetery
and then the trio of undead Creed's
descend on a young gage as the movie
ends it ups the horror quotient of the
film's final minutes quite a bit and
while that all fans will agree with the
new direction there's little doubt that
few of us saw it coming
serenity came and went as a blip on the
screen in the midst of a crowded year
for movies despite a cast that includes
Oscar winners Matthew McConaughey and
Anne Hathaway serenity is the story of a
fisherman in Boca
then who's obsessed with catching a pig
tuna that always seems to avoid him his
relatively boring life has changed when
his ex-wife shows up and offers him a
ton of money to kill her abusive new
husband so far all the ingredients for a
nice little thriller are there and then
it turns out that this is all happening
inside a video game that's right
the story of serenity is actually that a
13 year old boy has programmed a video
game as a therapeutic exercise to
reconnect with his dead father then he
decides to change the game's programming
when he realizes he wants to kill his
abusive stepfather then things get even
weirder when the game itself seems to
want to deny its own programming and
somehow prevent the murder you think the
biggest twist and spider-man far from
home would come from Mysterio the man
who uses super advanced illusion tech to
trick everyone into thinking he's a
superhero fighting off city destroying
monsters the trouble is a lot of people
guessed the twist that Mysterio was a
villain just from watching the film's
trailers and understanding that Mysterio
is traditionally a villain in the comics
to be truly surprised by a daring twist
you have to stick around until the mid
credit scene there it's revealed that
Mysterio doctored a video before his
death to make spider-man look like the
true villain of their struggle while
also outing Peter Parker as the man in
the mask this sudden change in the
character status quo plus the sudden
return of JK Simmons is Jay jonah
Jameson to the spider-man universe is
enough to make the audience feel as
shocked as Peter Parker set in 1969
Hollywood once upon a time in Hollywood
shows us a history of a tipping point
within both the film industry and Los
Angeles as a whole there's a sense of a
city and an art form on the brink and
Quentin Tarantino successfully creates
the feeling that anything might happen
then as the film reaches its climax he
drops the big twist it turns out that
anything can happen feeling is there to
set up Tarantino's dream version of
events a world in which Sharon Tate's
and her friends are never murdered by
the Manson Family and the family members
are instead bought off by clip booth and
Rick Dalton
Sharon survives Rick gets another shot
at a career and cliff is along for the
ride it's a bittersweet happily ever
after and one that lands even if you do
see it coming there are two major twists
in Joker and both are presented in a way
that creates a certain sense of
ambiguity so that you're not sure what
to believe the first arrives when it's
revealed that Arthur Fleck might
actually be the illegitimate son of
Swayne himself which makes him Bruce
Wayne's half-brother doubts is later
cast on this claim but Arthur seems to
cling to it and that attachment pays off
later the film's ending drops the second
major twist the riot arthur flack
inspired creates the environment in
which Bruce Wayne's parents were killed
so and the continuity of this movie the
Joker
inadvertently creates Batman does this
make the film too twisty for its own
good
your mileage may vary but there's no
doubt you left the theater thinking
about it
Shazam seemed to be a pretty traditional
superhero origin story as it follows
Billy Batson and his journey from orphan
boy to impossibly powerful superhero we
see Billy learning to use his new powers
in a mature way his connection to the
people who become his chosen family and
his eventual defeat to the supervillain
sivanna not just through brawn but
through the power of love the twist
comes in just how that love manifests
itself in the midst of his final battle
with sivanna Billy remembers the wizard
who gave him his powers hinted that he
would be able to share that power with
your heart unlock your greatest power
roams of our brothers and sisters await
Billy realizes that means that he must
pass his gifts on to his chosen family
and that's how in 2019 we got the Shazam
family on the big screen
the film's willingness to put such a
massive new development out there so
late in the story was part of what made
it so much fun one of the biggest keys
to parasite success is the way it lulls
you into thinking everything's going to
go one way before zipping off in another
unexpected direction the major turn
comes midway through the film just after
the Kim family has thoroughly
infiltrated the park family's lives at
this point director bong joon-ho has
expertly planted the seeds for what we
think is about to happen which is the
park family slow discovery that the Kim
family have calmed them then the
doorbell rings and the fired housekeeper
who we never expected to see again shows
up then she enters the park house again
and reveals both the secret bunker
beneath the structure and the man living
down there it's a brilliant turn that
subverts expectations and fits perfectly
within the film's framework knives out
provides ample opportunities for twists
and turns during its runtime and writer
director Rian Johnson delivers plenty
however the biggest plot twist at work
in knives out involves Harlan thrombi a
noted mystery writer who's found dead of
an apparent suicide at the beginning of
the film it's eventually revealed that
Farland did commit suicide after his
nurse Marta accidentally gave him what
she believed to be a fatal dose of
morphine Harlan killed himself
rather than risk Marta getting arrested
for a simple mistake but it turns out
there was even more to the story
in the end private investigator Benoit
Blanc reveals that Harlan's grandson
ransom actually switched the labels on
Harlan's medication to engineer the
morphine overdose but Martha gave Harlan
the right medication out of instinct so
the twist in the end is that there's not
a murder of any kind and that Harlan's
death really was just a misguided
suicide if you walk out of the
lighthouse and someone asks you what the
film's about so there's a good chance
you'll have some difficulty answering
that question yes it's the story of two
lighthouse keepers who seem to be slowly
losing their grip on sanity and reality
but if you really dig into the
intricacies of the film it's a lot more
complicated than that that said there's
still a powerful twist lying in wait
near the end of the film it comes when
the young wiki eeprom Winslet reveals
that his real name is Thomas Howard and
that Winslow was an identity he stole
from a man who died in a timber
accident that he didn't stop this
revelation and the guilt that comes with
it helps to add tremendous depth and
emotional weight to the film's powerful
climax plus there's the fact that the
twist means that both major characters
are named Thomas their similarities
contrasting against each other in
progressively more violent ways check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stop or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]